عندما نقلت خدمة الطائرة التجارية الأولى
الركاب بين
سانت بطرسبرغ فلوريدا وتامبا في عام
1914 ،
كانت الرحلة نفسها مثيرة بما يكفي
لدرجة أن الناس لم يكونوا بحاجة إلى الترفيه
حتى بعد أن غيّرت شاشات مسند الرأس
والأقراص السينمائية ما نفعله
عندما ننتقل إلى ترتيبات الجلوس
بشكل عام بقيت كما هي
لكن المساهم في CNN ، كريس جيمس ،
يستكشف الرؤى الجديدة للتصميمات الداخلية للطائرات على
الرغم من أنها قد لا تقلع فعليًا في
أي وقت قريبًا.
لقد اضطرت صناعة الطيران بشكل خاص إلى التكيف بطرق
لم يخطر ببالها من قبل أنها ممكنة ،
لذا في روح إعادة تصور
السفر الجوي اليوم ، سأعطيك
لمحة عما قد تبدو عليه الطائرة
المستقبلية الفائزين بأحدث
جوائز المقصورة الكريستالية.  أعلن مؤخرًا عن
تقديره لأفضل
المصممين الذين يدفعون
الهوية الأكثر إبداعًا وإثارة إلى الأمام  easy في
التصميمات الداخلية للطائرة
في القائمة المختصرة للجوائز الأصلية ، هذه
الفكرة المثيرة للاهتمام والتي تسمى مفهوم الصالة المرنة
والتي تسمح لركاب الطائرة بمواجهة
بعضهم البعض على متن طائرة من
بين الفائزين هذا العام هي
الطائرة النفاثة الكهربائية أليس التي فازت
في فئة مفاهيم المقصورة
بأنها الأولى بحتة
طائرة ركاب كهربائية
وقد تم اختيارها
لمقصورتها الداخلية المبتكرة التي يمكنها نقل ما يصل إلى
تسعة ركاب
على مسافة تزيد عن 600 ميل
نظرًا للطريقة التي تم بها تصميم المقاعد ،
سيواجه جميع الضيوف
النوافذ الكبيرة للطائرات.
تسمى
كابينة المقهى وقد تم تطويرها من
قبل الطلاب وأعضاء هيئة التدريس من
جامعة سينسيناتي
ووصفت بأنها منطقة تركز على الإنتاجية
وتستهدف مسافر الأعمال
، حيث سيكون لكل مسافر
محطة عمل مخصصة ومساحة شخصية
، كما أنها تتميز بهذه الجداول الموفرة للمساحة
الموجودة في  مركز
الطائرة نجاح باهر
الآن أنا أعرف ما الذي تفكر فيه
عند الإقلاع والهبوط تقريبًا خلال تلك
الأوقات ، ستدور المقاعد باتجاه
مقدمة
الطائرة وستطوي أجنحة الطاولة بشكل آمن
، من المثير دائمًا
التفكير في الطرق التي
سيتطور بها السفر بشكل
جيد في المستقبل